Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to buried. Now, it's story time again
because I just couldn't help but dive deeper because we were just scratching the surface
of what the hell was going on in this forest
and, does this have something to do
With some sort of contaiment system
For abnormal entities of some sort so, I just had to make another episode of it
So, get headphones on and crank up the volume
This is going to be a wild ride
*Reads screen/game*
Yeah Dennis seems to know a bit of something that he's not telling me
Yeah, we'll be fiiineeeeeee
You know, I wanna reassure him that we're going in the right direction
I mean, why wouldn't we be fine? A bnormal entities are on the outside of the building
Not in with us
*Reads screen/game*
You know what?
That may seem spooky, but footsteps?
Literally footsteps means it can't be bad monsters
And maybe, they are just scared 'cause they hear people talking
So let´s go right
"You decided to go into the darkness..."
Maybe not a good idea, but! here we go...
*Reads screen/game*
Yeah, I mean, honestly
We´'re looking for help- we're looking for anything. We need someone to talk to
And if there's someone here I wanna find them
...it could be our crew
*Reads screen/game*
Ehhh- ahhhh you know?
Mmmmhgghhh
ah, there's a risk! In calling out to them
But at the same time
If they hear a human voice  why would theyy.... shoot, first?
Why would they shoot first?
Why would they?
WHY would they shoot first?
Might be holding again, I'M willing to bet that it's something else
ahhhhhhh
Yeah why not? "Hey who's there?"
I'm, I'm, I'm willing to trust
*Reads screen/game*
Well... at least he didn't shoot us, so that's kind of a good thing
I mean, he's scared for a reason
But why was he standing alone at the platform anyway?
Very confusing...
*Reads screen/game*
I don't think Dennis is going to respond well to harsh criticism
He seems to respond to reassurance
We can DO this Dennis
We CAN do this
*Reads screen/game*
Do I yell out or do I stay quiet?
Well I mean I've been yelling nonstop thus far so might as well
"announce" my prescence to
all
here
I don't know what's the harm in yelling. We need help, we do
We DESPERATELY need help
I know it's not the smartest idea
*Reads screen/game*
Maybe it was a good idea maybe it wasn't, I've no idea...
Is the power back?
Has the power been restored??
Biuhhhhhip (alien noise)
Oh, okay
*Reads screen/game*
Okay...
That's weird...
So do I enter the conference room or the lab?
I feel like the lab might give me more answers...?
No, the lab would just confuse me
I wouldn't know what's going on the lab but the conference room might actually have some things
That they- whoever was here was discussing
'cause I'm just a lumberjack,
Look, I was just here to...
...JACK some lumber!(no, really?)
Best to get to the conference room and try to get things in ways that I can understand
*Reads screen/game*
White board would be the quiqest way to get information
Let's look at the papers on tha table
Oh shit
Well that's not good
Well, maybe I shouldn't have shouted out after this guy...
*Reads screen/game*
He's going to shoot you!
You can't close the distance!
*Reads screen/game*
"We're just loggers"
We're loggers!!!
-best to give him some details...
*Reads screen/game*
Best to give him a reason we we would be down here
We need to rationalize our existence and it's mind
We're new to him
It's obvious that he belongs here
I don't know why he's alone down here but,
we're looking for our crew
we literally came down here looking for our crew.
*Reads screen/game*
Nah, I'm not gonna grab his gun
please don't shoot me.
I'm stepping between that. yeah, I'm getting in the way. no way.
euh, best not to be sarcastic
No, punch him, he's richt there! punch him, punch him, PUNCH HIM
munch that man
No, no,no,no,no,no,no, come on now, come on, come on; one punch...
is enough, and awesome
let's take it easey, he's as stressed as we are
welp,  I should have my hard hat now, shouldn't I
so thath's inresting. if I had gone easey on him, he hit me in the eye.
but if I haden't one easy on him maybe  he woulden't have *beenabel* to give us anny answers, becous he would haven been uncounsious.
bet at least now he's awake.
I don't know if thats a good thing.
but I mean were all in this together, were obviously not ennemys
ihat doesn't look goed. that looks sinister. oh boy.
Before I get into the elevator with this guy I think it's wise to learn a bit more about him
I can tell it's making him uncomfortable for me to have the gun.
"What's your name" I ask.
"Marcus."
"And you work here?" It's clear that he doesn't wanna answer but he gives us a little nod.
"We're looking for the rest of our crew, any idea of where they might be?"
"No." he says, curtly, not bothering to elaborate.
There's got to be some useful information we can get out of this guy.
I just need to know how to dig for it.
"I need a first aid kit for my friend here, where might I find one?"
"Down on the second floor, but we can't go down there."
"What's on level 2?" Tell us what's on level 2.
He looks at me like I'm an idiot. "You must be aware that you are in a classified government facility." He says.
It makes sense but I wanna doubt it.
"Well, I'm sure the government would want you to help save my friend, so take me to the first aid kit."
"I can't, you don't have clearance. Hell I barely have clearance."
Then, seemingly to himself, he mutters "I make this place run."
"And not even a thank you. Just a bunch of restricted access rooms that I'm not allowed to go into with a freakin' chaperone."
"We're going to that first aid kit." I interrupt.
"I could lose my job!"
I wonder for a moment what sort of trouble I could get into for hitting a government employee.
This makes me glad I took it easy on him.
Then again he had come at us with a rifle, it makes me think that things have gone terribly wrong in this place.
And the explosion in the woods or what ever the hell happened, might be linked to it all.
I need to convince him to take us to the second floor, but I'm not sure if it would be more productive to threaten him or ask for sympathy.
Well threatening him might work, but...
He's obviously scared, we obviously have a gun...
I don't even know if sympathy would work on this guy, he seems really really high strong, and seemingly, seemingly...
Okay, for the little bit that I've seen of him he seems like a guy that takes his job very seriously,
even though he feels like he's been unappreciative.
So maybe threatening him would be the more direct way, but also, once he realizes who we are
and that we are actually saying who we are, threatening him might not be the best option.
So we could just literally ask we are in trouble, if this doesn't work then I know he's not gonna work.
"Look, it hasn't been the best day. We're just trying to find out what's going on, to find our crew, to survive."